hey guys it's vadim with maxtec and
welcome to our airpods buyer's guide for
2022 where i'm gonna give you guys all
of my experience with each different set
of earpods including the airpods second
gen the third gen the airpods pro and
the airpods max i'm going to talk about
the pros and cons of each one including
the different prices because they're all
on sale almost all of them are on sale
right now for basically the best deals
that we've ever seen for each set for
example the second genera pods are only
99
right now the third gen are 169 so 10
off not that good of a deal but the
airpods pro they are 74 off only 175
instead of 250 which is an absolutely
crazy good deal and then of course we
have the airpods max over ear headphones
a hundred dollars off on those so in
this video i'm going to share my
thoughts and experience with each one
and basically by the end of this video
you are going to know which set of
airpods to buy because i'm going to talk
about the battery life the different
features the convenience the controls
the sound quality everything else so
let's jump right into it now the first
ones i want to start off with is of
course the airpods second gen these are
by far the oldest ones that are still up
for sale right now and they're by far
the cheapest as well now one of the
biggest downsides that i want to point
out is that these airpods for 100
unfortunately come with the regular
wired charging case and not the wireless
model because that one is no longer for
sale so you've got to deal with that
lightning cable compared to the airpods
3 and the earpods pro which both have
wireless charging cases and not only
that they both support max save so if
you have mac safe for your iphone you
can use the same mac save charger to
magnetically connect your air pods and
charge them up which is really
convenient but i'd say that the biggest
downside by far for these airpods is
first of all you have that old design
and a lot of people made fun of it and
it definitely does not look as clean as
the newer airpods 3 in pro design which
has a shorter stem which i think looks a
lot better but
sound quality is where these ones really
are lacking because the airpods 3 and
the airpods pro are on a whole another
level especially in terms of the base so
you've got to be sacrificing that base
for the regular airpods i'd say really
the only people that should be buying
these regular airpods are those who are
really just on a budget they want to get
some airpods for the least amount of
money possible and that's where you can
win with these airpods second gen now in
terms of my personal experience i used
these for a while and they were very
very good the issue was of course the
sound quality not being that great but
the battery life was actually pretty
good but the biggest downside that i
remember from using these was the
annoying double tap controls which were
not that reliable and they were just
basically annoying and nowhere near as
good as the controls on the other
airpods so basically if you're trying to
get some super cheap air pods these are
still a good option because i think
later on this year these are going to be
completely discontinued now moving on to
the airpods 3 these are by far the
newest ones that just came out a few
months ago however there are a couple of
cons to these as well first of all the
price you're not getting as good of a
sale so it's only 10 bucks off and in
reality you can just pay six bucks more
for the airpods pro which i'm gonna talk
about in just a minute but in terms of
my experience with the airpods 3 first
of all the sound quality is great the
bass is super impressive considering
that they're not a sealed design they're
actually kind of open ear where they
just hang in there they're not sealed at
all and because of that some people can
have issues with their ear canals not
fitting the airpods 3 and that's one
reason why people would go for the
airpods pro but one of the biggest
issues with not having a sealed design
is sound
leakage these ones by far leak the most
amount of sound because they're quite a
bit louder than the airpods too so if
you're going on the bus a lot or out in
public be aware that if you're blasting
music people can probably hear that
around you so if that's a no-no for you
then you might want to avoid the airpods
3. but in general these ones have by far
the best battery life out of the airpods
2 and the airpods pro so it's very very
impressive you're getting about six
hours of battery life compared to five
for the second gen in 4.5
for the airpods pro because they have
the noise cancellation which i'm going
to talk about in just a minute and
that's actually one of the biggest
downsides that you're paying 170
and you're not getting any noise
cancellation however the controls on
these are excellent because all you do
is pinch the stem and it switches the
song pauses does whatever and it's just
super convenient and these also have the
adaptive eq which is very nice and of
course the newer design but in my
personal opinion because the sale is not
that good on these right now
i think you should probably skip out on
these and just go for the airpods pro as
long as they're on sale for this crazy
good price
175 dollars and there are a few reasons
why first of all these airpods pro have
by far
the best in-ear sealed design out of any
in-ear earphones on the market i'm not
kidding because these feature an
exclusive unique vent which basically as
soon as you put them into your ears it
allows some of the air pressure out of
your inner ear canal to release now on
top of that these have by far the
cleanest and tightest base because of
the sealed design compared to the
airpods 3. now another feature that you
can get with the airpods pro the airpods
3 and the airpods max is of course
spatial audio and i think that effect
does such a good job at making it feel
like you're in like an open room with
the sound kind of around you like in a
bigger wider sound stage but by far the
best feature of the airpods pro is the
noise cancellation feature and also the
transparency mode which basically allows
you to listen to music but also hear
your environment and they also do not
leak sound like the other airpods do now
in terms of the actual noise
cancellation performance they do a
really good job and for the average
person you're going to love it because
it blocks out the extra noise and just
allows you to focus and be calm and
peaceful and do your studying work
whatever you want to do without having
to blast your music to drown out that
external noise however the noise
canceling isn't the best because if you
want the best you've got to go with the
air pods max now these are completely
different they're over ear headphones so
they're obviously a lot bulkier i'd say
the airpods max are for those who just
really really want to relax and enjoy
like the best quality music the best
quality speakers being able to hear all
those little instruments that you can't
hear with the other airpods and in terms
of the noise cancellation these are top
notch you can literally put them on and
bring up your music and you won't hear
anything around you literally you won't
hear anything and in terms of the actual
build quality these are by far the best
built headphones that i have ever seen
or experienced it's all metal and the
fabric on the headband is just so soft
and it doesn't put pressure on the top
of your head i love the little digital
crown for adjusting the volume then you
also have the side button for switching
between noise cancellation and
transparency mode which by the way works
excellent on these as well and i know
that spending 450 dollars with the sale
price is a little bit hard to swallow
but if you have the extra cash these are
worth it because you get a totally
different sound quality experience and
these are just such high quality in
terms of the build quality however we do
actually have some leaks and rumors in
terms of which airpods are going to be
updated next now there are a lot of
leaks that later on in 2022 sometime in
the fall we are going to be getting
airpods pro 2 and the biggest feature
that a lot of people are expecting
including myself
is lossless audio support coming to
wireless airpods which right now is not
possible because airpods are using
bluetooth so i think apple is going to
use some kind of different codec
potentially an ultra wide u1 ship so i
think that's coming later on this year
and they might potentially have a
stemless design as well so that's going
to be convenient now in terms of the
airpods max mark german believes that
apple is going to be releasing some new
colors maybe a different case or
something like that and i think they
might be coming at the end of this year
or apple might delay them just so they
don't clash with the airpods pro so
maybe next year we might get new airpods
max and if we do they are for sure also
going to be getting lossless support
which is by far the biggest drawback
right now to the regular airpods max
because they don't support
lossless over wireless which is
unfortunate so with that said hopefully
this video helped you make a decision on
which airpods to buy and if it did go
ahead and click the circle about to
subscribe for more videos like this one
and check out one of those two right
over there thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next video